nous allons vous interpréter une chanson
qui ne fait pas partie de mon répertoire
has mais que j'adore particulièrement et
tout enction temps je vais vous
interpréter avec mes tris petits
camarades que je vous représente
d'ailleurs parce fond il le mérite
Jean-Marie d' François Jan et Gaston et
moi-même sur une chanson que je vous ai
dit très spécialement ce
soir comment
[Musique]
resp
Mar
guantanam c'était un H
déroute c'était un frère sans
doute il navait ni lien ni
placees et sur les
routes de l'exil sur les sentiers sur
les
place il me parlait de sa
ville
Guantanamera ma ville
Guantanamera
guantanam ma ville
guantanam là-bas sa maison de
misère était plus blanche que le coton
les rues de sable et de
terre Sant le
Rome volon sous leur jupons de
nelle Dieu que les fillesit
B
Guama ma vie
[Musique]
guantama
guant ma
[Musique]
Viant
ma
[Musique]
qu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la